bills are now four and three and a lot
of people are tending to blame it on
Josh Allen some weeks he looked like an
MVP and some weeks he seems to struggle
I always said when Josh Allen is on he's
on there he's Unstoppable Josh Allen
that beat the Miami Dolphins is the
Unstoppable Josh Allen I think often
sometimes you play down to your
competition and you make simple mistakes
because you're overly confident I think
sometimes Josh plays overly confident uh
he truly believes in his abilities he
truly believes in everything he does and
my God should he and we shouldn't take
away his confidence I just think
sometimes he has to know when to let the
play go and things like that Josh still
has a chance to turn this around and he
just has to bounce back you know the
games that he lost he's shouldn't have
lost so those are paying ones you know
you don't want to lose those games